[Musik]
einen wunderschönen guten abend her aus
dem bild live studio sowie der nach acht
dem topf der schlagzeilen macht und
heute geht es um alles impfpflicht 2 ghz
putin mit ganz besonderen gästen bei uns
ist es doch blos
cdu-chefin hamburg und
bundestagsabgeordneter und zugeschaltet
aber irgendwie hier auch im studio sahra
wagenknecht per telefon zugeschaltet
weil sie kurzfristig an corona erkranken
bei uns auch bild live chef claus strunz
und natürlich meine kollegin nina schenk
bessel autorin und moderatorin bei hätte
nach acht aber zunächst interessiert
unsere zuschauer natürlich wie es sarah
wagenknecht geht der artikel heute bei
bild.de wurde millionenfach abgerufen
die menschen haben sich damit
beschäftigt wie geht es sarah
wagenknecht die ja immer wieder gesagt
hat dass sie sich nicht hat impfen
lassen und jetzt mit krone angesteckt
hat frau wagenknecht sie sind uns
telefonisch zugeschaltet wie geht sie ja
ich wollte ja sagen ich habe natürlich
schon eine gewisse sorge gehabt
irgendwann ein positives ergebnis zu
bekommen das war jetzt auf absehbar oder
gar nicht zu überraschen bisher geht mit
dem glück und ich merke gar nicht ich
hoffe einfach macht es ändert sich mehr
in den nächsten tagen oder werden dann
zumindest schon ein milder verlaufen es
gibt ja viele zuschauer auch hierbei
viertel nach acht die immer über
impfpflicht diskutieren über das impfen
und viele fragen sich soll ich mich doch
noch impfen lassen oder soll es bleiben
lassen wenn sie jetzt corona bekommen
haben denken sie sie hätten es doch
besser machen sollen oder denken sie
jetzt
ist es passiert
also ich finde es muss jeder für sich
entscheiden also bei mir gab es einfach
auch bestimmte gesundheitliche gründe
warum ich mich nicht impfen lassen
wollte weil ich sorge hatte dass ich da
bestimmte dinge verstärken könnten und
letztlich ja es muss halt jeder sein
risiko abwägen also je älter jemand ist
oder wenn er bestimmte erkrankungen hat
diabetes zum beispiel oder sehr starkes
übergewicht da weiß man da ist das
risiko eben sehr hoch da ist es
sicherlich auch empfehlenswert sich
impfen zu lassen junge leute mögen das
anders sehen ich finde einfach es ist
das recht von jedem dass selbst zu
entscheiden
wenn sie jetzt darüber nachdenken dass
die impfpflicht eben viel diskutiert
worden ist und die frage für sie zu
hause wie verhalten sie sich jetzt in
den nächsten tagen und haben sie sorge
dass sie möglicherweise verwandte
angehörige angesteckt haben könnten ja
ich habe zum glück die letzten tage
eigentlich sehr zurückgezogen verbracht
also ich war zu hause und da ist mein
mann auf guten partner der einzige der
da im risiko ist ansonsten ja man hat er
sich angestellt nicht dass wir wissen
also hat es keinen test bis jetzt
gemacht weil das ja inzwischen auch
nicht mehr so ist dass man das immer
muss aber oder auch überhaupt sollte
aber es geht ihm gut und insoweit hoffe
ich mal dass ich da ihn auch nicht
angesteckt habe und ich werde natürlich
die nächsten tage zu hause bleiben ist
ja völlig klar und auch niemanden mehr
treffen weil ich möchte ja auch
niemanden gefährden also das ist ja
völlig selbstverständlich wir freuen uns
dass es ihnen gut geht aber wir wollen
hier bei 48 natürlich auch diskutieren
und sie haben ein thema mitgebracht was
sie am heutigen tag besonders bewegt hat
ja wir haben ja heute im bundestag die
erste impfpflicht debatte orientierung
debatte erlebt ich habe dir konnte hause
aus verfolgt und ich muss sagen ich
finde die argumente der befürworter
wirklich
nach wie vor überhaupt nicht überzeugend
also selbstbestimmte argumente die man
im herbst vielleicht noch bringen konnte
wird inzwischen nicht mehr wirklich
relevant weil die mikrowelle lässt sich
ja durch die impfung oder ins licht
ohnehin nicht später die ihr wollt jetzt
solche sehr viele menschen werden sich
infizieren und jetzt ist das
hauptargument der impfpflicht
befürworter das würde ich mich brauchen
damit für im herbstlich schon wieder in
eine neue infektionsfälle klein kommen
aber ich muss sagen da sind mir zu viele
wenn und zu viele nicht für viele nicht
wissen ist mit dem spiel also erstens
viele biologen erwarten jetzt dass
tatsächlich nach oregon wir in eine
sogenannte ende kommen also dass das
leben durch die abschwächung die wir mit
objekten ja sehen die mildere zur neu
für das ist dadurch eben die bevölkerung
so stark infiziert das gibt viele
menschen auch immun sind und dass wir
dann keine pandemie mehr haben und auch
womöglich nicht mehr diese belastungen
gesundheitssystem das weiß natürlich
niemand herr lauterbach
prognostiziert ja schon wieder
irgendwelche grusel mutanten die im
herbst kommen die da wieder viel viel
gefährlicher sind natürlich könnte das
theoretisch auch sein ich glaube das
kann niemand ausschließen aber selbst
dann wissen wir nicht ob die jetztigen
impfstoffe gegen diese mutanten
überhaupt wirken wir sehen ja schon bei
auch mikron dürfen wir sehr viel weniger
wir wissen auch nicht ob ein impfschutz
sehr früh erworben wird im herbst noch
wirklich voll da ist das war im letzten
jahr das problem die die früher der
frühzeitig gibt wurden hatten im herbst
einen nachlassenden impfschutzes hinter
dem poster und all das sind ja doch
dinge die der im wagen liegen und unter
solchen voraussetzungen jetzt menschen
zu verpflichten sich zu impfen ich finde
das kann man einfach nicht rechtfertigen
das ist ja ein sehr sehr gravierender
eingriff in die körperliche
unversehrtheit und dafür muss es
wirklich zwingende gründe geben bei dem
brocken damals da hatte man einen
impfstoff mit dem man das virus
ausrotten konnte bei der nase und
impfung hat man einen impfstoff wo jeder
dicker sein kann er kann niemanden mehr
anstecken er kann sich auch nie wieder
in betrieb da gab es und gibt es im
pflichten aber das sind völlig andere
voraussetzungen als bewohner und ich
würde mir vielmehr wünschen wenn man
sich auf den herbst vorbereiten will und
das sollte man tun dass endlich
ernsthaft etwas gegen den pflegenotstand
unternommen wird und dagegen dass in den
krankenhäusern eben immer wieder
überlastungen sind weil das kennen wir
doch schon vor krone auf fortuna gab
immer in großen grippewellen die
situation dass intensivstation voll
waren des patienten verlegt werden
mussten dass operationen verschoben
werden mussten und das zeigt uns doch
wir müssen dringend mehr ressourcen in
das gesundheitssystem investieren
bessere gehälter zahlen mehr
pflegekräfte aber eher lauterbach macht
das gegenteil mit der einrichtung
bezogenen impfpflicht wird sich der
pflegenotstand zu schärfen und dann
wieder zu sagen ja jetzt haben wir
wieder eine noch größere belastung und
wir haben müssen wieder grundrechte
einschränken ich finde aus dieser
spirale müssen wir raus kommen
bloß wenn sie da diese argumente von
frau wagenknecht werden wie können sie
da sagen wir brauchen diese im
vielleicht trotzdem also zunächst möchte
ich erst mal gute besserung wünschen und
hoffe dass es ihr bald wieder gut geht
und ich kann die argumente durchaus
nachvollziehen das will ich als jemand
der zu einer impfpflicht tendiert auch
ausdrücklich sagen das ist keine
einfache debatte natürlich ist das auch
ein schwerer eingriff und ein eingriff
in die freiheit eines individuums aber
umgekehrt ist es doch so dass wir im
moment seit einigen wochen eine art
locker und leid haben und als
gesellschaft mit massiven grund und
freizeit schenkungen leben müssen dass
wir in vielen bundesländern
über die kapazitäten auf den
intensivstationen schon hinaus waren
patienten ausgeflogen werden mussten und
das was jetzt kommen sie wieder und drei
strecken die villa und das
gesundheitssystem schon auch wirklich am
rande der kapazitätsgrenzen stammende
studie etwa es nur noch in sachsen in
bayern mussten ja patienten auch in
andere bundesländer ausgeflogen werden
wollen das auch schon in anderen
krankheitsfällen passiert ja aber das
corona dann natürlich für eine besonders
schwerwiegende situation in den
krankenhäusern sorgt das ist glaube ich
offenkundig und wird auch niemand
bestreiten und jetzt ist ja die frage
wenn wir auf den nächsten herbst und
winter schauen wollen wir das gleiche
noch mal durchspielen und ich möchte
unbedingt verhindern dass es zu weiteren
krawallen kommt und dass wir weitere
lockdown erleben und ich glaube in der
abwägung ist dann eine impfpflicht da
kann man jetzt diskutieren ob ab 50 oder
ab 18 doch der bessere weg weil ich
befürchte dass wir ansonsten in jedem
winter und herbst das gleiche erleben
wie in den letzten zwei jahren sie habe
viele interessante sachen gesagt aber
das interessanteste wort ist sie
tendieren zu einer impfpflicht können
sie denn noch umstimmen
also ich bin natürlich immer guten
argumenten aufgeschlossen aber ich bin
schon überzeugt dass eine impfpflicht
hilft es gibt ein argument das hat er
auf frau wagenknecht eben vorgetragen
würden tatsächlich jetzt wir in die
endemische lage kommen und wir das ist
ja die hoffnung zumindest von einigen
wir wissen dass im moment noch nicht
corona so eine art schnupfen wird und
wir damit sehr gut umgehen können dann
glaube ich gibt es tatsächlich keine
gründe mehr für eine impfpflicht weil
wir dann damit gut umgehen können dann
kann ich ihn dann beweis liefern nämlich
ganz persönlich ich habe bereits zum
zweiten mal corona bekommen weil meine
reise in kiew und war dreifach geimpft
die wirkung dessen war das ist wirklich
nur schnupfen war tatsächlich allerdings
frage ich mich wenn wir politiker auch
aus ihrer partei erzählt haben in den
vergangenen monaten und jahren
das ist doch so sein dass man damit
corona dann nicht mehr bekommt und ich
ist jetzt schon zum zweiten mal bekommen
habe dann frage ich mich wussten die
politiker eigentlich worüber sie reden
und waren diese impfstoffe wirklich so
gut und ich verstehe diese erklärung die
da jetzt kommen nämlich ja
möglicherweise gibt es dann ja wieder
eine grusel mutation so hat frau
wagenknecht das finde ich sehr treffend
bezeichnet und dann braucht man ja
vielleicht ein impfstoff der irgendwie
vielleicht wirkt aber keiner weiß
irgendwas genauso wie können sie denn da
die mir dass wir das wissen tatsächlich
dann die menschen verpflichten so an
impfstoff ja dann
zu nehmen das ist tatsächlich ja das
große problem bei der korona krise
insgesamt dass wir immer wieder neue
entwicklungen haben die keiner
vorausahnen konnte und dass wir
eventuell auch entwicklung bekommen
werden in den nächsten monaten die wir
heute in dieser runde und in ganz
deutschland gar nicht vorausahnen können
soll deswegen kann es immer sein dass
man das auch hierunter anpassen muss
auch die fdp zum beispiel hat er ihre
position zur impfpflicht sehr stark
verändert aber ich kann das ganze auch
umdrehen wenn wir jetzt sehen wir haben
weitere mutationen die bei einer
geringen impfquote dazu führen dass die
intensivstation schnell überlastet sind
dann werde ich doch im nächsten herbst
und winter wieder über wochen grund und
frites einschränkungen haben und die
pflegekräfte die kommen irgendwann an
ihr limit und wenn frau wagenknecht sagt
sie möchte die pflegekräfte entlasten da
muss sie mal mit vielen pflegekräften
sprechen denn die sagen wenn wir noch
mal so was erleben dann hören wir bald
auf und gehen woanders nina wie siehst
du das die impfpflicht es wissen die
zuschauer scheint nicht dass du klar
dagegen willst dann wenn man jetzt die
argumente höher aufweisen also erst muss
ich sagen dass ich frau wagenknecht sehr
dankbar bin dass sie sich als politikern
auch öffentlich immer so dagegen stellt
und ich muss ja auch für rückgrat
gratulieren ich fand es großartig dass
sie das auch weiterhin wie sie von ihrer
eigene medizinische entscheidung
überzeugt wenn durchgezogen hat auch im
öffentlichen druck weil das ist es das
impfen ist eine medizinisch persönliche
entscheidung die jeder für sich alleine
trifft ich finde es furchtbar dass es
heutzutage so ist jeder sagt seinen
impfstatus früher hat meine ich eben
erst mal seinen impfbuch gezeigt wenn
man sich getroffen hat beispielsweise
zum kaffee heute ist dass so was nicht
ganz toll stört an dieser impfpflicht
und weswegen ich ist furchtbar finde
auch wenn ich natürlich respektiere wie
du darüber denkt finde ich es furchtbar
wenn ich daran denke dass menschen dazu
gezwungen werden dann ist es kein zwang
aber sie werden ja immer mehr dazu
gebracht geflüchtete verpflichtet es ist
eine impfpflicht keinen impfzwang groß
und ist aber ich sage ganz gleich wie
gegen die impfpflicht wir dürfen
menschen doch keinen medizinischen
eingriff auf doktrinen und ich habe eine
frage noch die die mir auch sehr wichtig
ist es gibt ja auch impfen
nebenwirkungen und darüber reden wir
viel zu wenig im deutschen fernsehen wir
leben generell viel zu wenig darüber es
gibt aber impfnebenwirkungen in meinem
bekanntenkreis oder sogar familienkreis
gibt es auch einen fall wo im
nebenwirkungen aufgetreten sind es sind
natürlich einzelfälle aber es gibt es
das heißt die frage ist wirklich wie
kannst du jemanden verpflichten sich
impfen zu lassen und ihnen dazu ja
eigentlich dann zwingend immer mehr
hintreiben was ist wenn dieser mensch
plötzlich impfschäden hat es ist immer
die möglichkeiten beim mediziner statt
also das ist ja völlig klar dass das
wirklich eine schwierige entscheidung
ist und das ist auch solche fälle leider
gibt aber es ist gerade in der politik
bei so schwierigen fangen immer eine
abwägung und ich kann das auch umdrehen
und sagen ist wurden im winter dieses
jahres und ende letzten jahres
operationen verschoben von menschen die
krebs hatten oder haben es wurden hätten
sie ohne dabei die kapazitäten einfach
nicht da waren es wollen alle
kapazitäten teilweise in den
krankenhäusern zusammengezogen um die
korona patienten zu versorgen oder auf
den intensivstationen mitzuhelfen so und
dann gibt es natürlich massive grund und
freizeit einschränkung auch für
gewerbetreibende die in den schulen hat
man das gemerkt also alle wissen das ja
in dem fußballstadion der bild hat ja
häufig auch darüber berichtet und jetzt
ist doch die frage wollen wir das alles
wieder riskieren dass wir sagen im
nächsten herbst und winter haben wir
eventuell wieder drei monate so eine
situation und in den krankenhäusern
es wird den krebskranken patienten
gesagt tut mir leid operation muss
verschoben werden das wird nicht kann
man nicht akzeptieren
politiker sind die in aller regel
schlaue leute und sie haben sicherlich
auch ihre früheren parteichefin immer
gut zugehört die gesagt hat man muss
dinge ja vom ende her denken das war
eine ehre großen wenn wir jetzt eine
impfpflicht einführen und die bringt
aber nix weil leute werden weiter krank
corona erkranken um mikro oder c gründen
oder große mutationen und wir haben
sozusagen trotz einer impfpflicht trotz
des umstands dass ultima ratio gezogen
hat weiter dieses große das land
beeinträchtigende die menschlichen das
menschliche zusammenleben
beeinträchtigende phänomen plus es gibt
im folgen die wir jetzt noch gar nicht
absehen können was erzählen sie dann den
naja ich hab damals war damals halt mit
gestimmt und jetzt wieder anders und
haben wir wieder was dazugelernt zu den
erfolgen kann man ja eins sagen es gab
ja sehr umfangreiche klinische studien
und man hat ja nicht anderen impfstoff
auf den markt gegeben und sagt das sind
jetzt alles versuchskaninchen
deswegen bin ich da sehr zuversichtlich
dass ich irgendwelche im spiel wirklich
überschaubarem maße sehr stark in
grenzen halten und wie gesagt es ist
eine abwägung umgekehrt gibt es sehr
viele die erkrankten die dann auch
sterben und die intensivstation werden
überlastet aber natürlich hilft das nur
am ende wenn es auch sinnvoll ist und
wenn es dazu beiträgt dass zum beispiel
die intensivstation nicht überlastet
werden wenn der loire und häufig das
gehirn berliner von der hinter- und
ihrer partei nicht sinnvoll war aber
klaus du machst das thema was corona
angeht weiter up system wird ja ich hab
die impfpflicht den takt im mittel mit
großer faszination verfolgt und habe was
festgestellt was mich eigentlich
überrascht hat die politik habt immer
wieder in die gleiche falle und macht
immer wieder den gleichen fehler sie
will nämlich am besten alles für alle
und am besten für immer regeln und dabei
wäre es aber viel besser punktuell
vorzugehen und sich ein konkretes
problem ehrlich vor augen zu führen und
es dann konkret zu lösen was meine ich
damit wenn wir uns zurück erinnern als
die ersten wellen gebrochen werden
mussten wie es damals hieß von cola gab
es lockt bei uns und ausgangssperren und
restaurants waren lahmgelegt und
geschäfte und vereine und schulen und
kindergärten dabei hätte es genügt die
altenheime zu schützen und damit konkret
leben zu retten als es dann bei allen
schon klar war dass draußen an der
frischen luft nichts passieren kann man
sich eigentlich nicht ansteckt gab es in
vielen städten in allen teilen
deutschlands plötzlich masken pflicht
beim joggen beim spazierengehen leute
wurden beim spazierengehen angedeutet
holt sie abstand obwohl längst klar was
da passiert und jetzt also da hätte man
sich viel lieber auf die sprayer
hotspots richtig konzentrieren sollen
aber nein man hat die menschen beim
spaziergehen belässt und jetzt jetzt
also die allgemeine impfpflicht für alle
ab 18 ist einer der anträge um die es
geht um meine frage lautet wer sich viel
besser zu sagen wer sind eigentlich die
die am ende des gesundheitssystem
belasten werden wenn sie sich nicht
impfen lassen denn in den krankenhäusern
und auf den intensivstationen kommen
menschen über 60 an die vorerkrankungen
haben und ungeimpft sind das ist die
zielgruppe um es einmal deutlich zu
sagen und ich frage mich warum die
politik nicht alles auf wert um diese
zielgruppe nur diese zielgruppe dazu zu
bringen sich impfen zu lassen mit
konzentrierten werbeaktionen von mir aus
sagt man rentnern eine monatsrente
zurück gegen impfungen und man macht
also impft brennenden mann macht
persönliche gespräche der bundeskanzler
schreibt persönlich alle über 60
jährigen an er ruft sie per video an und
macht sie selber darauf aufmerksam was
seine verantwortung sie haben das alles
geschieht aber nicht stattdessen werden
kerngesunde 22-jährige verdammt sich mit
der spritze da irgendwie in impfstoffen
am rand das geht mir nicht ein also doch
lieber konkret vor allem ein punktuell
vor allem müssen sozusagen darunter
leiden oder sind davon betroffen ein
problem klar benennen und es klar lösen
hilft mehr als alle zu belästigt
klar sie kann ihr da nur zustimmen und
auch wenn ich schon vermutet dass frau
wahnsinnig vielleicht auch zustimmt
können wir ja mal fragen wie sehen wie
das frau wagenknecht
also werben natürlich vor allem bei den
älteren das finde ich richtig weil da
ist die gefahr groß aber ich finde auch
bei den älteren das ist ja jetzt ja auch
nicht anders gesagt worden aber ich will
es noch mal ausdrücklich sagen also ich
bin auch gegen eine pflicht ab 60 oder
ab 50 oder wann auch immer weil auch
ältere menschen das volle recht haben
sich über ihren körper selber zu
entscheiden und ich wollte auch wirklich
einmal noch die zahlen nennen weil das
immer wieder so gesagt wird so pauschal
die überlastung des gesundheitssystems
ich meine wir hatten im letzten herbst
auf der bei der del tabelle in der
spitze
4800 gruner patienten auf den
intensivstationen
wir haben aber alleine im letzten jahr
wegen des pflegenotstands über 5000
intensivbetten abgebaut das heißt wenn
die politik wenigstens dafür gesorgt
hatte dass die kapazitäten konstant
bleiben also dass wir nicht mal ausbauen
müssen aber wenigstens konstant bleiben
dann hätte wären die koma patientin gar
nicht ins gewicht gefallen und ich finde
man immer wieder sagt also die menschen
sollen sich so etwas verpflichten müsste
auch die 50 mal ihre hausaufgaben machen
und deswegen also verpflichtung für
älteren einwerben bei älteren jahr das
halte ich für richtig auch aufklärung
alles richtig aber ich finde auch die
impflücken bei den älteren wenn wir die
zahlen sehen die es da gibt und die
realistischen zahlen also man muss ja
sagen das lka wir sind ja in einem
datenblatt blindflug wir wissen ja auch
noch nicht mal die genaue info.de in
deutschland aber das lka sagt immer ist
die reale ist 5 prozentpunkte höher als
die ausgewiesene weil viele impfungen
nicht gemeldet wurden dann heißt das wir
sind bei den über 60-jährigen real bei
einer impfquote von 93 prozent vor und
ich muss sagen also die sieben prozent
das muss unser gesundheitssystem im
notfall verkraften und ein teil davon
ist wahrscheinlich sogar schon gelesen
pro wagen nicht viele menschen haben die
debatte auch heute verfolgt eben um die
impfpflicht darum was die politik jetzt
macht aus ihrer sicht glauben sie dass
am ende eine impfpflicht kommen wird
oder werden da bei der spd bei den
grünen bei der fdp auch diejenigen
überwiegen die sagen moment mal omikron
das ist doch nicht mehr so gefährlich
und was wissen wir was dagegen der
nächste bilder hilft
[Musik]
aber der
politische diskurs hat sich mehr und
mehr von denen von dieser realen basis
abgekoppelt jetzt geht es eigentlich
darum schuld hat angekündigt als kanzler
er will die impfpflicht die cdu rückt
ihn jetzt und sagt ja zeigt auch mal
dass du führungsstärke hast so ungefähr
und die ampel oder zumindest die spd die
fdp steht ja aus aber zumindest die spd
versteht das jetzt irgendwie als ein
führungsversagen wenn sie davon abgehen
und das ist eine gefährliche dynamik
weil das eben bedeutet dass man nicht so
sehr offen für argumente oder
entwicklungen ist sondern jetzt in
dieser politischen eigenlogik meint man
muss jetzt beweisen dass man das
durchsetzen an und ich hoffe wirklich
dass man irgendwann merkt das ist ein
denkbar ungeeignetes thema um jetzt
führungsstärke zu diskutieren also bei
solchen gravierenden entscheidungen muss
es wirklich um das medizinisch
notwendige gehen deswegen es ist
vielleicht noch offen aber so richtig
ich würde zumindest noch nicht sagen
dass es begraben ist also sehr schon
einige die das unbedingt wollen sehr
spannende analyse verwackelt applaus wie
viel rechthaberei ist da auch bei ihnen
in der partei sie haben sich doch mal
festgelegt und gesagt mensch wir wollen
die impfpflicht wir sind ja das team
vorsicht auch bei der leute die da muss
ich wieder da muss ich als verbrechen
wie viel rechnet das kabarett ist dabei
ihre ideen zwar gibt es für uns keine
rechthaberei das mag in anderen
fraktionen einmal das niveau aber wir
haben uns tatsächlich ja bisher nicht
festgelegt sondern wir haben eine sache
klar formuliert und das will ich hier
auch nochmal betonen wir haben eine
bundesregierung die gerade bei solchen
wichtigen fragen eigentlich initiative
in den bundestag einbringen muss die
auch einen administrativen apparat die
ministerien hat die
behördenmitarbeiter hat die auch die
entsprechenden gesetze ausarbeiten
müssen und die natürlich auf viele
fragen beantworten können mit fachlicher
expertise über die wir hier in der runde
auch gesprochen haben und dass all das
die bundesregierung bisher nicht gemacht
aber das ist ja die feinheiten
bei dem weil wir im bunde hier die welt
der name klingt ja ganz interessant was
vorwagen nicht gesagt bei uns haben der
vorwurf ist ja hier bin ich habe ja
schon was ich hier habe ich ja gar keine
position festgelegt als cdu und csu
deswegen kann man uns diesen vorwürfen
machen zum beispiel gegen genau deswegen
bei uns wird das ja auch kontrovers aber
es darf nicht sein was nicht sein darf
gerade oder also ich habe heute auch
herrn stegner mal gefragt ob er
eigentlich sozusagen es wagen könnte
jetzt wo sein kanzler und sein
gesundheitsminister sagen mensch leute
wir machen uns die impfpflicht sorgt
durch stege aus dem norden ich bin
anderer meinung da hat dann natürlich
gesagt ich da stehe ich sage immer meine
meinung aber natürlich ist es zu spüren
dass das von olaf scholz wie ich finde
in der geste eines großen demokraten ins
parlament verwiesene thema verbunden mit
ein abgeordneter ist nur seinem gewissen
und nicht der fraktion verantwortlich so
soll die abstimmung sein wandert sich
jetzt schon wieder zurecht in es ist
trotzdem dann am ende schwierig
schwierig schwierig wenn man in der spd
ist und anders abstimmt als der
lauterbach unterstützt und es werden
viele nicht machen zumal man dann
übrigens abstimmt wie die böse afd das
ist ja quasi mit einer politischen
todesstrafe das bestraft wenn rauskommt
dass du abgestimmtes tweedy afd man
durfte ja wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal
sagen ich finde auch dass im osten die
sonne aufgeht wenn die afg festgestellt
dass im osten die sonne aufgeht also ich
sehe hier schon wirkungs kräfte die dazu
führen können dass abgeordnete die
eigentlich gegen die impfpflicht während
halb dann sagen komm mama derzeit und
das ist bei dieser wichtigen frage einer
der wenigen fragen die an dem körper von
jedem einzelnen menschen rennen ragend
nicht nur an sein intellekt an seinen
fünf dann seine gespräche richtig hand
anlegt an dem körper zu leichtfertig
neben der impfpflicht ein thema was dich
besonders beschäftigt hat auch in den
vergangenen tagen immer wieder zwei g2
gipfel ja und da hast du die schafe
meinung mitgebracht jedes beschäftigt
mich ja seit der einführung muss sich
jetzt wirklich mal sagen ich finde es
gibt nichts schlimmeres eigentlich mit
aktuell als zweig in deutschland ich
finde es furchtbar
wir grenzen menschen aus und es erklärt
sich mir die sinnhaftigkeit nicht also
das ist eigentlich für mich aktuell das
schlimmste ich verstehe die regelung
nicht einmal mehr als beispiel wer
silvester da sind auch bekannte von mir
aber man hat ja generell auch die fotos
sind in den skiurlaub gefahren haben
schön party gemacht ein rein getrunken
und was war am ende kamen alle mit krone
nach hause das heißt die geburtsdaten
dürfen feiern dürfen zusammen im club
sitzen aber menschen die sich gegen die
impfung persönlich entschieden haben
dürfen nicht mals für ihre kinder und
jetzt muss ich auch mal emotional werden
weil die die immer für alles
argumentieren argumentieren ja auch
immer mit den kindern war ich jetzt auch
mal die dürfen nicht mehr als für ihre
kinder schulutensilien kaufen die dürfen
nicht mal für ihre kinder eine mütze
kaufen wenn sie die verlieren das tun
kinder übrigens öfter die muss jetzt
online bestellt werden und das ist für
mich ein absoluter wahnsinn
und ich frage mich wie wir als land das
weiter mitmachen wollen zweig ich frage
mich wie politiker weiter in den spiegel
schauen können die das zu verantworten
haben und dementsprechend ist mein
appell ganz klar einführung von 3g
flächendeckend und zwar so vor sofort
zweige plus ist übrigens doch absurd da
womit fange ich jetzt gar nicht erst an
wenn ja ich finde vor allem ein aspekt
beunruhigend muss ich sagen nämlich die
frage was das eine mit unserer
wirtschaft macht ich habe viele freunde
die ihr restaurant dichtmachen mussten
ihre bar dichtmachen mussten ihr
geschäft dichtmachen mussten weil das
alles so nicht mehr funktioniert und ist
ja nicht nur das eine sondern es gibt
die omikron welle wo alle in quarantäne
müssen obwohl ich kann es ja aus eigener
erfahrung berichten dass wirklich nur
ein leichter schnupfen ist und in
anderen ländern man nach wenigen tagen
wieder raus darf aber in deutschland da
haben wir unsere festen regeln und da
darf keiner raus zuvor das nicht
irgendwie wie auch immer frei getestet
wurde so und das ist das eine das trifft
die geschäfte wahnsinnig hat die
einzelhändler all das was uns ja wieder
absolut jetzt immer noch die
plexiglasscheiben und was sie alles
machen mussten um öffnen zu dürfen das
haben jetzt auch wieder irrelevant was
sie aufgebaut haben der größte witz paar
wenn ich das auch sagen da ich hab mich
fürchterlich aufgeregt am samstag in
düsseldorf ich war draußen essen passt
hier selten
wir sagen sogar draußen unter den
heizstrahlern weil die haben ja alle
aufgebaut indes offenbar noch
außengastronomie zu schaffen mehr platz
und dann fragt mich der kellner nach
meinem haus wahr ist dann habe ich ihn
vor gezahlt hat er gesagt ich muss noch
sehen dass es drei von drei ist wenn sie
das kann ich ihnen auch gerne zeigen ich
bin ja gewusst hat aber ich möchte sie
jetzt ganz ehrlich mal fragen wozu denn
ich sitze hier draußen an der frischen
luft der nächste tisches ein meter
entfernt mit meinen beiden freundinnen
und eine freundin von uns sie hätte dann
auch gar nicht mehr dazu kommen können
wir alle schnell
testmöglichkeiten also doppelt games
konnten keinen schnelltest mehr machen
draußen in der außengastronomie muss ich
mich da gerne einmal frau war ich wieder
mit dahin nehmen
fragen vielleicht haben versuche hört
macht das alles noch irgendwie sinn und
gibt es da noch eine logik in der
politik was corona angeht also ich
glaube epidemiologisch hat zweig noch
nie sinn gemacht also zunächst wurde das
ja so begründe das angeblich die
ungeimpften die großen bären schleudern
sind und deswegen draußen bleiben müssen
und wir wissen heute dass das begründet
wurde teilweise mit zahlen die wirklich
verfälscht waren also das waren ja die
berühmten inzidenz von herrn söder und
der center die sozusagen alle
infektionen wo man den impfstatus nicht
kannte den mit denen umgehen zu
gerechnet hatte hatte man astronomische
intelligenzen unter um games noch besser
die müssen jetzt überall draußen bleiben
inzwischen weiß man geimpfte selbst
gebuchte jeder kann sich anstecken jeder
kann auch andere anstecken bayern gibt
es da überhaupt keinen unterschied mehr
als doppelt geimpfte sich sogar öfter
anstecken und die jetzt hat man eine
neue begründung jetzt sagt man ja man
muss die ungeimpften quasi vor sich
selber schützen also dass sie sich nicht
anstecken bei den anderen deswegen
müssen sie draußen bleiben also das ist
so fadenscheinig und da finde ich hat
makro also der französische präsident
war in dem punkt zwar noch ehrlicher der
hat die 2g eingeführt mit der begründung
er will die ungeimpften schikanieren hat
er ganz klar gesagt er will die
ungewissen schikanieren damit sie
endlich sich impfen lassen und dann muss
ich sagen das war zumindest eine
ehrliche ansage also sind ich noch
besser als die heuchelei die dann über
irgendwelche begründungen vorschiebt die
einfach nicht stimmen aber natürlich ist
es nicht verfassungsgemäß menschen zu
schikanieren weil sie ein recht
wahrnehmen und noch gibt es in
deutschland so wie eben auch in
frankreich gar keine impfpflicht für
alle und deswegen finde ich also zweig
geht überhaupt nicht ich bekomme auch
wirklich ganz viele mails von leuten die
mir tragische situation schreiben an sie
können nicht mehr mit ihren kindern ins
schwimmbad können ihr kind irgendwo
anders hin begleiten jugendliche können
nicht mehr im sport club trainieren
obwohl dass sie ihre gesundheit wichtig
ist nur weil sie eben noch nicht geimpft
sind oder sich auch dagegen entschieden
haben also das ist alles absurd und ich
hoffe mal dass das irgendwann ein ende
hat
und
jetzt wird so getan als könne man sich
all dieser probleme entledigen wenn man
nur dieser verdammten impfpflicht
zustimmt das argument habe ich heute im
bundestag ungefähr 20 mal gehört also
das gegengeschäft lautet alle maßnahmen
weg dieser ganze quatsch und unsinn weg
musste dir halt nur eine spritze setzen
lassen das muss man sich immer vorstellt
ich denke mir auch oft wenn wir vor zwei
jahren sozusagen
prognostiziert hätten dass in unserem
land so was geschieht dann hätten uns
die leute für verrückt halten das wäre
selbst für einen science fiction roman
zu viel gewesen weil er in dem man nicht
verkauft ich muss mal ich muss mal
massiv ihr widersprechen da auch gerade
was frau wagenknecht gesagt hat liegende
frage stellen wie wir gerne jahre diese
haben sie schikaniert mit ihrer partei
bei den regeln and also dass die regel
natürlich extrem hart waren und auch
wirklich diese grund und frites
einschränkung alles andere als leicht
sind ist doch klar ich gehöre übrigens
auch immer zu denjenigen die gesagt
haben wir dürfen diese grund und
freiheitsrechten nicht zum dauerzustand
machen und ich habe genauso wie es der
stunde auch formuliert hat immer wieder
darauf hingewiesen dass viele maßnahmen
nicht zielgenau sind also zum beispiel
hamburg haben wir erlebt dass spd und
grünen den masken pflicht für jogger
verhängt haben also anders als da
draußen mit maske zum joggen am
wochenende ist natürlich idiotisch und
viele regeln kann man nicht
nachvollziehen noch mal ein beispiel aus
hamburg die elbphilharmonie ist drinnen
gefüllt da sind die leute dicht gedrängt
zusammen und ein fußballstadion was
draußen ist 55 60.000 zuschauer umfasst
da dürfen dann irgendwie 2000 leute sich
ein derby hsv gegen pauli anschauen das
kann man nicht nachvollziehen deswegen
da muss man immer wieder den finger in
die wunde legen so was auch völlig fatal
ist und den eindruck hat jetzt frau
wagenknecht hier erweckt es ist als ob
es völlig egal sei ob man sich impfen
lässt oder nicht und das zeigen ja nun
wirklich alle studien dass die impfquote
schon sehr sehr wichtig ist da in bezug
auf den zustand der intensivstation des
gesundheitswesens aber auch damit
natürlich das virus sich nicht
ausbreiten und wird dann immer über zur
einschränkung zur frage war ob dann zwar
gerechtfertigt ist naja zweig führt
natürlich einerseits dazu dass
diejenigen die dann geimpft sind die
auch geschützt sind dass die sich dass
die sich relativ sicher sein können und
zumindest sicher dass sie nicht
angesteckt werden und sicher dass sie
nicht auf der intensivstation dann alle
ja auch wieder eine studie lesen mit
rein vergab mich wieder angesteckt haben
ist die 2g nicht jahre ja wann zahlen
natürlich gibt es immer durchbrüche und
wir wissen gerade bei uniqa und gibt es
auch relativ viele leute lama aber wir
wissen auch dass natürlich die geimpften
viel bessere verläuft haben im schnitt
jetzt gehen sie über vorwürfe gerade
haben sie haben einmal keine rolle weil
den ländern das burgenland also es ist
ja völlig unterschiedliche dinge also
geimpft haben natürlich ein viel
geringeres risiko an koronaren und wenn
sie erkranken uns ein impf durchbruch
gibt dann ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
viel geringer dass sie auf der
intensivstation landen so dass er
einfach nicht die leute sind besser
geschützt und das sorgt am ende
natürlich auch dafür dass das
gesundheitswesen
dass die intensivstation nicht
überlastet werden wenn die im chor ist
wenn hier niedriger sie ist desto höher
ist die gefahr einer überlastung und
natürlich auch eine verbreitung des
virus und ich glaube weshalb er die
langen lang applaus deswegen ist schon
wichtig dass wir an der hohen empfohlen
arbeit frau bank nicht wie lange
den eindruck als ob es völlig egal wie
lange noch immer gemeinden wie lang
eindruck ich weiß es nicht ich
glaube dass also das hängt jetzt sehe
ich will gar nicht spekulieren weil ich
es wirklich nicht weiß wenn man
tatsächlich das wäre jetzt das beste
szenario in bald in endemische lage
kommen corona sich zur so eine art
schnupfen entwickelt dann können wir
zweig sehr schnell abschaffen sodann
kann sagen wir ein paar wochen schon
sagen wir leben wieder so weit es geht
wie vorher wenn es aber mutanten gibt
dann kann es natürlich sein sodass wir
werden uns aber vielleicht noch jahre
das weiß kann es gibt ja schon zumuten
so der mann gibt ja schon viel mutiger
rundete die sagen es gibt die
möglichkeit dass das in die in dem ich
lebe passiert aber ich weiß das nicht
sagen was wo es wichtig ist dass ich
vorher sage ich bin doppelt geimpft
werden bunt gemustert aber wie wäre es
denn wenn man sich überlegen würde wie
man es zu hause regeln würde also wenn
ich ein essen geben würde für zehn leute
wer mir nur ein einziges gen wichtig
nämlich getestet heute ob die leute ob
meine gäste sicher impfen haben lassen
und meine gäste genesen sind weil sie
krank waren ob meine gäste sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen weil sie vielleicht
über luther klaus der versuch das
problem nicht so dass test nicht hinter
deutschland das habe ich ja nur den
gedanken einmal du ich weiß ja dass er
irgendwie weit von der aber alle reden
über 3g 2g wie wär's denn mit 1 g und
dann aber dafür tests an jeder ecke also
wie kaugummikauen da müssen wir uns
natürlich fast 100 prozent sicher sein
was ist denn immer 100% anliegen der
schule oder auch habe die fed weiter mit
dem einen punkt machen ganz kurz zu
fraglich weil sie keine zinsen sondern
ist uns ja zugeschaltet ich würde gern
auch an ihre meinungen und das nicht
einfach so stehen lassen und zwar dass
sie den eindruck erweckt hat das impfen
gar nichts bringt so habe ich sie noch
nie verstanden vielleicht will frau
wagen kann ich dazu nur die rückantwort
sagen weil sie kann ja nicht selber man
sollte aber bitte aussagen wie sie die
impfquote verbessern möchte weil das das
mit aufklärung und werbung nicht so
zufriedenstellend läuft wie man es
bräuchte das haben wir gesehen dass
waren nicht an bord
die impfquote verbessern oder muss die
aus ihrer sicht überhaupt verbessert
werden ja also erstmal bin ich dankbar
dass ich jetzt noch mal rein kommen weil
ich tatsächlich das nicht gern so stehen
lassen würde natürlich weiß man dass die
impfungen vor schweren verläufen schützt
oder zumindest die wahrscheinlichkeit
mit einem schweren verlauf konfrontiert
zu sein deutlich verringert der schutz
ist zeitlich begrenzt also der lässt
nahe wenn die impfung mehrere monate
zurückliegt aber er ist erst mal ein
ganz wichtiger fakt und deswegen habe
ich dafür dass ältere menschen sich
impfen lassen ohne jede frage und wer
als junger mann sich also da ist ein
risiko so abwegig dass er sagt ich habe
mehr angst vor der erkrankung der sollte
sich auch impfen lassen ich bin ja nur
dafür dass es jeder für sich entscheiden
kann also ich bin nicht jemand der jetzt
um gottes willen man soll sich nicht
impfen lassen also dass er völlig
bescheuert und gerade bei älteren leuten
wäre es verantwortungslos was zu
erzählen aber was hat die impfquote
angeht wie gesagt ich habe ja vorhin war
daraufhin gewesen also ein deutsches
problem in corona ist dass wir
eigentlich so gar nicht irgendwie
verlässliche daten haben nicht einmal
zur impfquote offiziell ist jetzt 73 das
lka sagt wahrscheinlich sind fünf
prozentpunkte mehr da werden wir bei 78
prozent
da sind wir unter den fünf ländern in
europa mit den höchsten impfquoten als
wir stehen dann an fünfter stelle alle
anderen haben weniger und trotzdem
diskutieren die meisten länder nicht
über eine allgemeine impfpflicht also
wir sind gar nicht so schlecht wenn man
jetzt mal gut und schlecht mit mit der
höhe der inflation setzen will wie das
immer dargestellt wird wir haben eine
wahrscheinlich also relativ gute
impfquote wir haben vor allem bei den
älteren das hatte ich ja vorhin gesagt
nimm quote von rund 93 prozent bei den
über 60-jährigen und wir haben jetzt vor
allem auch ganz viele die eben mit dem
virus in kontakt kommen sich war sie
natürlich postern weil sie einfach ja
eine infektion bekommen und ich fand
interessant dass die amerikanische
gesundheitsbehörde jetzt noch mal gesagt
hat uns ganz im gegensatz zu herrn
lauterbach weg für entscheidungen vor
kurzem die haben gesagt der genesenen
sind deutlich längerfristig gegen
schwere verläufe geschützt als die
geimpften und da sollte man auch mal zur
kenntnis nehmen das heißt wenn jetzt
sehr viele menschen auch gerade wenn sie
vorher games sind in den risikogruppen
ist es ja gut wenn sie vorher gibt dann
aber wenn sie dann jetzt mit dem virus
in kontakt um dann haben sie quasi bauen
sie einen immunschutz aus wo ich die
hoffnung habe dass der dann auch im
winter weiter hält sich die bahn oder
andere frage wir müssen einmal ganz kurz
in dieser hitzigen und spannenden
debatte in die werbung gehen und dann
kommen wir zurück und diskutieren weiter
bei viertel nach acht
[Musik]
also da kann ich einen lauten und nicht
ernst nehmen als sogenannten experten
sie bekommen meine damen und herren
viertel nach acht tagen der schlagend
sein machen mein name ist wieder fit
so nicht
herr jörges wetten dass aber niemand von
den politischen parteien traut sich zu
sagen ja das wollen wir einfach nur
freiheit diese grün-roten der damen
führen hochtrabende debatten über die
rettung des weltklimas und um die füße
ruhen die ratten das thema ist viel zu
wichtig um es nur der afg zugewandt
lasst den leuten noch mal einen spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatale ist
in der politik bei den journalisten
deren job ist es doch gerade abweichende
meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch wichtig
das tragen eines quasi zum manko
vielleicht einmal sein das auto im märz
haben wir ganz nennen doch das ist
übliche andrack träger außerdem stehen
überdies bringen ich habe meinen beifall
um eine sache immer bekommen er kümmert
sich darum niemand ist federer man muss
da ganz kleinen auch darüber sprechen
ganz einfach nicht wer endlich richtig
ist die karte mädchen nicht mehr glauben
nur noch vierter
[Musik]
schön gut amt zurück bei viertel nach
acht dem topf der schlagzeilen hat heute
eine ganz ganz besonders hitzige
spannende und diskussionsfreudige runde
insbesondere dadurch dass sahra
wagenknecht auch bei uns ist und
zugeschaltet nicht bei uns ist
zugeschaltet per telefon corona krank
die hiermit diskutiert und wir möchten
weiter diskutieren über corona und ich
möchte ihnen sagen ich bin nur noch
wütend wütend darauf was mir politiker
in den vergangenen wochen und monaten
erzählt haben denn stellen sie sich vor
ich bin dreimal geimpft jetzt sehen wir
hier zwar bilder von wladimir putin der
dort möglicherweise auch über sputnik
und den impfstoff spricht aber ich kann
ihnen sagen ich rege mich vor allem über
deutsche politiker auf stellen sie sich
vor ich bin dreimal geimpft ich habe
mich mit corona angesteckt 2020 also bin
ich einmal genießen und was ist vor zwei
wochen passiert ich habe mich wieder mit
corona angesteckt ich bin also jetzt
doppelt genießen und dreifach punkten
der super super super limone unter uns
aber dennoch wollen politiker erzählt
dass diese in pflicht sein muss es geht
einfach nicht anders okay ich habe es am
anfang irgendwie noch verstanden da hat
man mir erklärt ja ja eine impfung
schützt uns dann gegen kommen der
ansteckung geschützt dagegen aber als
ich dann gedacht hat mensch ich bin
gelesen ich war dreifach geimpft und
jetzt habe ich mich wieder angesteckt so
frage ich wie kann das denn passieren
wie konnte das denn sein und da gab es
politiker in allen parteien war der spd
bei der cdu der bundeskanzler der
vizekanzler alle haben mir erzählt nein
nein das ist alles schon wahnsinnig
sinnvoll was wir hier besprechen und
diskutieren
die wahrheit ist doch die politiker
ändern ihre meinung in dieser frage fast
wöchentlich und das ist dieser stress
welches bild dort abgegeben wird denn
jetzt und das ist wirklich die absolute
wahnsinns aussage in dieser debatte da
erzählt man uns doch ernsthaft man müsse
sich durch die impfung für den nächsten
varianten schützen ja bitte also stellen
sie sich vor ich gelesen dreifaches
jetzt wieder genesen ich glaube ich
krieg bewohner noch mal
politiker haben wieder quatsch erzählt
wenn ich ein corona virus wäre würde ich
mich schlapp lachen wie sozusagen hier
ein land über jahre und seine politiker
über monate und monate zu unsinnigsten
dingen verleiten kann ich glaube aber
dass diese emotionale republik licher
einen totalen wendepunkt auslöst in der
politik denn ab sofort muss dann fünf
gelten nur wer zwei mal genießen drei
mal geimpft ist kann künftig noch im
fernsehstudio ich muss dann leider
ist es ist tatsächlich verrückt und er
selber als tragisches im jahr und ist ja
gar nicht so also einer stichwahl die
ich war vereinfachen sie müssen eine
herrsche noch immer nicht genau ich
sagen okay ich schließe dich verloren
hat paramus man muss er einen sagen
jetzt ohne dass ich die einzelnen
verläufe alle bis hin zur zeit kann
ich ganz einfach
da war ein bisschen schnupfen 20 20 40
mich doch da habe ich mir noch diese
sauerstoffgerät geholt und machen
konnten ist das jetzt schlimm oder aber
und jetzt war es so ich habe nochmals
mit schnupfen gehabt ein bisschen
kopfweh quarantäne quarantäne sie dürfen
nicht 1000 gefährdeten menschheit aber
das liegt vielleicht auch daran dass sie
dann ging waren so weil man ja weiß wenn
man geimpft ist dann hat man
aber jetzt wechseln ja immer die logik
dahinter die logik also ich persönlich
wechsel die gar nicht weil ich sagt wenn
wir eine höhere info.de haben dann haben
wir genau solche verläufe vielleicht
häufiger wie bei ihnen wenn wir keine
geringe impfquote haben dann haben wir
viel mehr menschen die auf den
intensivstationen landen und dann ja all
die folgeprobleme über die wir
gesprochen haben belastung der
intensivstation
von rund um die
heilung war aber schon anders also ich
bin jetzt wirklich kein wahnsinnig
naives teilchen aber als ich mich zum
ersten mal impfen lassen waren die
erzählung wenn man sich impfen ist
kriegt man es nicht mehr stimmt also war
die hab ich ja nicht wieso wir nicht
auch der nach einer feier und natürlich
habe ich habe mich daran auch geglaubt
ich könnte sogar sagen vertraut und
jetzt bin ich ja doch
natürlich gehen ja gar nicht wieder
springen also wenn sie wenn sie sich
aussagen anschauen vom märz 2020 vom
herbst weiter und 20 natürlich sind die
zum großteil überholt und meine hoff ich
kann noch sagen vom halben jahr hätte
ich gesagt okay nach der zweiten impfung
sind wir wahrscheinlich alle übern berg
brauchen gar nicht eine booster impfung
da wussten wir doch gar nicht in
deutschland was boostern ist bis auf
ganz wenige ausnahmen und hatten wir das
so gut dann leben wir wieder normal nur
das ist ja nicht so dass ich jetzt hier
sitze und paar andere im bundestag die
sagen wir ändern mal das virus damit wir
diese debatte weiterführen das sind ja
einfach mutationen in den weg legen wo
die lager eigenliebe viele die viele
andere länder die viele andere länder
auch gerade erleben deswegen haben wir
auch eine impfpflicht in italien
eingeführt deswegen gibt es diese sie
haben sie die initiative nennt es wege
gibt es eine impfpflicht in italien
eingeführt wurde deswegen hat der makro
in frankreich gar nicht das ist ja nicht
so ist wie hier losgelöst von der welt
wären aber nur über wasser und italien
das ja ist ja noch nein sagen soll man
dann eva maria andere beispiele haben
andere hinten drauf reagiert eigentlich
wir alle die hier in der runde sitzen
beschäftigen sich jeden tag eigentlich
mit dem thema corona wir lesen zeitungen
wir schauen tv
was glauben sie was denken die menschen
die nicht so viel mit medien und politik
zu tun haben über das was ihnen da dann
hin und wieder von den politikern in
sachen corona erklärt wird ich glaube
ich schon immer mehr menschen auf das
sich das oft widerspricht also das oft
dinge erzählt werden und später so unter
der hand die gleiche maßnahme ist mit
anderen begründungen versehen wird oder
gar nichts mehr begründet wird also zum
beispiel als man jetzt den genesenen
status über nacht auf drei monate
verringert hat als einziges land also
alle anderen ländern bis sechs monate im
bundestag sechs monate aber ansonsten
für alle normalsterblichen dollar 3 da
wurde ja noch nicht nur eine begründung
mitgeliefert und ich glaube dass viele
leute einfach nur den kopf schütteln ich
meine natürlich ist man als laie in
dieser frage auch immer so ein bisschen
ausgeliefert also ich bin ich bin ja nur
weil ich auch nicht von meiner kompetenz
ja irgendwie virologen oder medizinerin
ich bin ökonomen also das heißt ich habe
auch dadurch dass ich relativ viel
gelesen habe versucht mir überhaupt eine
meinung zu bilden und wenn man sich um
tut dann findet man ja auch verschiedene
meinungen von geologen also nicht immer
nur die die hauptsächlich von der
regierung befragt werden und dann kann
man vielleicht auch eine differenzierte
sicht entwickeln aber ich merke ja wie
viel zeit das braucht und wenn man jetzt
jeden tag also acht stunden oder
vielleicht sogar noch einen zweitjob hat
also arbeitet und familie und so werden
diese zeit das heißt man merkt nur
irgendwie und ich glaube das merken
schon viele dass ich das widerspricht
was die politik erzählt dass einige
politiker zumindest immer den den alarm
modus an haben also immer das
schlimmstmögliche prognostizieren also
unser gesundheitsminister ist da ein
spezialfall und natürlich manchmal tritt
das schlimmer auch ein oft hat es zum
glück nicht ein aber ich finde es ist
eben auch schlechte politik immer den
leuten angst einzureden so kann man so
macht man ja auch das ganze
gesellschaftliche klima kaputt wenn
leute immer angst haben dann verhalten
sie sich ja irgendwann auch komisch das
ist echt ein problem
es gibt ja eine spannende analyse dieser
angstmacherei klaus die hat ja sehr sehr
gut funktioniert aus politischer sicht
muss man sagen wir markus söder der vom
jumbojet gesprochen hat der abt 4 und
viktoria 100 euro und der sn den wert
nach oben und diejenigen die eher
vorsichtig waren und auch ausgleichen
und wie zum beispiel armin laschet der
hat wahnsinnig verloren also oder karl
lauterbach zum beispiel ist auch gutes
beispiel dafür der ja auch eher
analytisch war und in den
beliebtheitswerten auf platz eins ist
also sind wir hier die
minderheitsmeinung das kann vielleicht
sogar sein aber ich bin merke schon eine
starke drehung also die werte von
microsoft sind jetzt nicht mehr die
allerbesten karl lauterbach handelt sich
jetzt in amt wo er nicht mehr sagen kann
wie man es richtig machen muss sondern
wird ersichtlich machen muss
selber machen muss handelt sich glaube
ich viel viel viel kritik ein ich will
auch einmal bei aller anekdotischen
zuspitzung sagen das ist schon schwierig
den richtigen kurs zu finden aber angst
und panik verbreiten da bin ich ganz bei
vor wagenknecht ist für politiker das
allerletzte was sie anstreben und es
gibt ja übrigens bei der kampagne fürs
impfen da gibt es ein wunderbares
beispiel aus frankreich dabei gibt es
eine tolle kampagne
sonst eigentlich läuft auf den gedanken
raus menschen das sieht wahnsinnig
sympathische leute wie sie sich umarmen
wie sie sich küssen und dann ist etwas
so der gedankengang wenn wir uns alle
impfen lassen dann können wir bald diese
szenen wieder erleben und da hab ich mir
überlegt wie werden die kampagne wohl in
deutschland und die kampagne in
deutschland wäre küssen bringt tod und
deshalb und das ist exakt sozusagen das
exakte unterschied ich glaube dass
menschen extrem im positiven sinne sind
verführbar durch positive emotionen
durch klar machen warum es gutes etwas
zu tun und nicht durch wenn du jetzt das
nicht machen müssen wir alle sterben und
ich habe ja das führt jetzt ein bisschen
weg keine sorge bin gleich wieder da ich
habe ja die angst dass diese methode
angst machen um ein ziel zu erreichen am
ende der code ist den politiker aus
dieser krise mitnehmen also abends nach
22 uhr nicht mehr auto fahren sonst
müssen wir alle sterben wegen der umwelt
ja jetzt lachen alle ich hätte aber auch
nicht gedacht dass man seinen hund nicht
mehr ausführen darf nur weil ein
bisschen kroner ist also insofern das
ist das was mir angst macht deswegen ist
mein punkt die schlimmste longo wird
folge ist nicht dass man ein bisschen
länger braucht bis man wieder marathon
laufen kann sondern die schlimmste longo
wird folge ist dass diese demokratie
eine delle bekommt die man lange nicht
mehr weg lasst das darf nicht sein also
dass wir es gibt ja einige auch bei der
grünen jugend die jetzt schon ankommen
sagen es muss danach weitere
freiheitseinschränkung geben mit der
begründung ist wichtig für das klima da
sind wir völlig einer meinung das darf
nicht passieren und krimis wegen es ja
meine begründung ist ja auch eine
positive also ich versuche ein positives
bild zu schaffen das ist und sie haben
auch sie haben auch einen richtigen
punkt gemacht wenn man sich mal die
werbekampagnen anschaut fürs impfen in
frankreich küssende menschen ein tolles
foto in deutschland irgendwie eine
kampagne die er darin erinnert als ob
nie
langweilig geworden langweiliges
schnarchen der liebe aber er schloss
damit wir noch über robert habeck
sprechen können so bewegend aber
vielleicht möchten sie auch in unserem
zusammenhang vorüber und herbergs
bewohner politik sprechen dass das mach
ich dass meine natürlich ein
übrigens problem das werde ich
wir haben ja tatsächlich neben corona
und auch andere wichtige themen und
diese woche ist eine bombe geplatzt oder
es kam völlig überraschend die nachricht
dass robert habeck in zukunft ein
förderprogramm einstellt dass
klimafreundliches bauen ermöglichen soll
und da gibt es keine lange frist von
einigen wochen oder monaten sondern das
hat er sofort gemacht viele häuslebauer
viele menschen in deutschland die genau
mit diesem förderprogramm ihren hausbau
kalkuliert hatten die gucken jetzt in
die röhre die können ihren hausboot
teilweise nicht mehr finanzieren und
auch in zukunft werden vielen familien
gelder fehlen gelder um ihre häuser
klimafreundlich zu bauen und das ist
wirklich ein schlag ins gesicht für alle
diejenigen die
attraktives die günstiges die
klimafreundliches bauen sich in
deutschland wünschen dass ausgerechnet
ein grüner minister als im prinzip als
erste amtshandlung die förderprogramme
für klimafreundliches bauen streicht das
geht gar nicht deswegen meine forderung
robert habeck bitte stoppen sie diese
politische entscheidung machen sie ihren
fehler rückgängig wir brauchen auch in
zukunft förderprogramme für
klimafreundliches bauen in deutschland
also was wirkliche frechheit ist ist es
auch ohne lange fristen zu machen denn
jeder der schon mal irgendwie geld der
immobilie investiert hat weiß er dass
man der anlauf braucht wenn man bauen
will braucht man erst recht anlauf dann
muss man planungssicherheit haben
planungssicherheit hat im kern vertrauen
auf das was geld und wenn sich dann
schnell was ändert ist es furchtbar ich
finde auch noch was anderes furchtbar
wir beklagen doch alle immer das in
deutschland zur altersvorsorge die
eigenen vier wände die in anderen
ländern eine viel größere rolle bei
menschen spielt sie sagen wir haben
unsere eigenen vier wände werden
wohnungen wir haben ein kleines haus da
steckt ganz viel drin diese möglichkeit
wird jetzt ja erst mal wenn ich für
unmöglich so doch erschwert und das
führt glaube ich zu dingen die in eine
ganz ganz falsche richtung gehen und
drückt auch dem robert habeck den ich
eben wie aus einer anderen perspektive
bewundere hätte ich fast gesagt aber
respektiere nämlich dass er wirklich
sein weg geht und auch wirklich
glaubhaft versichert er will eine
veränderte art wie wir sozusagen mit dem
thema umwelt umgehen da würde ich sagen
da bin ich nicht immer seiner meinung
aber das imponiert mir wir sozusagen
vorangeht da liegt er voll daneben ein
ausrufezeichen hinter die grünen die
haben sich ja im leben auch schon immer
sehr imponiert
wie ist deine haltung ich bin ja nicht
grün das habe ich ja schon mal
öffentlich gemacht kann ich jetzt gern
wieder sagen ich frage mich auch ein
bisschen ich bin etwas verwundert klaus
was die jetzt so stark imponiert nehmen
wir zum beispiel windrad
windkrafträder die wollen die grünen und
jetzt direkt vors haus bauen und die
entwertung das ist eigentlich ist es
wirklich also was die grünen vorhaben
ist eine ökodiktatur für mich nach wie
vor und ich verabscheue die
sozialistischen ansätze sind nicht sehr
froh dass das thema heute abend welche
branchen ansatz also da habe ich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt in der ampel regierung
noch nicht so viel sozialismus anreise
nicht durchgesetzt dabei die fdp ist ja
auch dabei noch mal ein unding spd ist
aktuell moderate ich will nochmal einmal
versuchen meine gedanken uns sozusagen
zu sortieren was mir imponiert ja also
ich finde die geschwindigkeit mit der
die grünen dinge umsetzen wollen falsch
weil sie die menschen nicht mitnehmen
aber ich finde manches von dem was sie
anstreben richtig und mir imponiert dass
sie tatsächlich ein anderes
zusammenleben ein zukunftsorientiertes
zusammenleben zumindest für mich
glaubhaft anstreben und dass sie auch
die schrittfolge sozusagen angehen weil
di resta tagen startet das ist das was
ich der früheren regierung vorwerfen
dass sie gerade in denen fragen klima
etc nicht vorangekommen ich glaube das
wird ein ganz ganz wichtiges thema sein
in der zukunft noch aber gegen ende der
sendung möchte ich noch einmal sahra
wagenknecht mit reinnehmen vorwagen echt
wir haben jetzt eine stunde diskutiert
geht es ihnen schlechter schon mit ihrer
kollegin
nur über gruner reden
ich würde mir auch dass also wirklich
wünschen auch deshalb wünsche ich mir
dass diese pandemie zu ende geht werden
so viele auch andere wichtige
gesellschaftliche fragen über die
eigentlich kaum noch geredet wird also
das soziale fragen sind ob das eben auch
die frage von umwelt ist oder auch die
frage ob das was die grünen unter grüner
politik verstehen überhaupt irgendwie
der umwelt und dem klima das sind ja
alles ganz wichtige fragen die sind alle
zu unter ferner liefen und am rand und
ich hoffe einfach dass wir bald wieder
auch die den kopf dafür frei haben und
auch nicht jeden abend sozusagen die
abendnachrichten und alles was an
nachrücken einem so überflutet nur mit
corona bevor wir vorweg nicht wenn wie
lange dauert das jetzt bis sie wieder
raus dürfen aus der quarantäne und
freuen sie sich darüber dass sie dann
diesen genesenen status haben wo sie
über rein dürfen na ja das hängt also
wann ich wieder rauskommen das hängt
davon ab wie ist ja verkürzt worden ob
ich mich frei texte also sprich ob ich
dann eben negative testergebnisse habe
der genesenen status denen habe ich das
habe ich jetzt auch erst gelernt
tatsächlich aus 28 tage nach meinem
positiven test also ein monat und dann
auch nur für ein mann gehöre also noch
nicht mal drei sind dass wir dann fragen
sind leider ist unsere sendung schon
vorbei vorwagen ich herzlichen dank
spannende sendung führte nach acht der
tochter schlagzeilen macht
[Musik]